should have owned her nose
oh hello everyone
i'm william devane why aren't you
picking up when i call you don't you
idiots like gold
it's okay it's good to see you we'll get
to the big news in a minute but first
let's enjoy a blast from the past my
attorney and i are committed to making
sure that everyone finds out the truth
and the facts
of what happened and i give my word that
we will not rest until that happens the
president trusted
mr cohen as his fixer for years he
trusted him with his innermost secrets
and i think that the chickens are about
to come home to roost
they did
those were the days those press
conferences were tough for her though
cause she kept grabbing the microphone
with both hands
because she's a porn star anyway and him
he was the shiny slippery litigating
lollipop once they were darlings of the
media now one's in jail and the other's
in the poor house thanks mainly to the
d-bag who's in jail he was convicted by
a jury of 12 and what she's done with a
group of 12 is available on vhs
i kind of miss him which is why it's
time for
the stormy weather center
see we did there we are so clever
monday stormy lost her appeal in her
failed defamation suit against donald
trump she tried to sue the pants off him
partly because she's not used to seeing
men still wearing their pants
but it's true she not only lost her
appeal figuratively she lost it
literally
worse the ruling has her owing almost
300 grand in legal fees to the former
president i can't wait to see how high a
stack of three hundred thousand one
dollar bills is
daniel said in a statement tuesday that
avenatti had sued trump without my
permission and against my wishes
something tells me over the years she's
accused a lot of guys of the very same
thing in the vip room
and now monday she tweeted i will go to
jail before i pay a penny
which reminds me
do you know what today is
[Music]
world math day
it is
and what a better way to celebrate than
to run the numbers so after daniels and
baldy lost the case the judge ruled that
daniels must cover trump's attorney fees
which is 293 grand
so
if the going fee for a lap dance is say
20 bucks how many lap dances will stormy
have to give in order to cover that fee
is it a 3400 b 8900
or c 14650
i'm going to give you all a moment to
work on this
is there music there should be
time's up that felt good all right
the answer is
c 14
650. that's more lapse than leah thomas
swam in the 500 freestyle
anyway storm is going to have to do 10
dances a night for four years straight
so take the batteries out of the smoke
detectors because that's a lot of
friction
meanwhile trump hailed the ruling
calling it a total and complete victory
in vindication for and of me we went to
him for further comment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
never get tired of that he dances like
someone who just got out of a body cast
true this decision was made by the very
liberal ninth u.s circuit court which is
refreshing
for it tells you that even if the media
falls for something stupid the law
doesn't and shouldn't sure the press
turned daniels into a martyr and
avenatti into her superhero they wanted
to believe so badly they made stars out
of two grifters straight from central
casting a lawyer even sleazier than the
expired porn star he was ripping off it
was all too much to swallow
that's a joke even i won't touch but we
knew it was a crusade that was about as
real as stormy's breasts which seems to
be the story today about trump
vindication in so many permutations the
laptop story now that's suddenly real
again and the claims about joe's
moderation well they weren't remember
when biden was supposed to be the calm
after the storm or stormy now it's the
reverse trump was the calm before the
storm or rather the storm the economy
under trump was fine under joe it's a
wreck meanwhile crimes exploded wars
breaking out the world is less safe and
more anxious
buyer's rewards is actually biden
remorse as we look into the rear view
mirror for trump wondering if maybe our
media was a tad too hard on the guy
oh tad too hard i think he started one
of stormy's films
but even the polls are showing this one
from emerson college not only showed
trump with a 59 favorability rating but
a 12 point advantage over bidens of
course the media still hates him and
still blames him for everything and we
get it they hated trump because they
couldn't control him and especially his
tweets which pierced through the media's
phony stories like a hollow-point bullet
through a marshmallow no wonder they
were banned so where are we now in this
post-trump world well the media is
telling us that we need to eat lentils
put our dogs to sleep and give up our
cars gas is at six bucks a gallon in la
there's crime inflation overdoses death
under trump the only stress was
psychological but ephemeral coming from
funny tweets and fleeting but relentless
insults it was like following don
rickles on twitter but under joe it's
not scary words but scary deeds we went
from a president who insulted
celebrities to a toothless doofus
stumbling into world war iii
reality is now a fun house mirror where
thugs are protected and the citizens
punished but in this reverse universe at
least porn stars now pay you for sex or
at least donald trump no wonder he's
always smiling we know it ain't gas from
eating lentils it's from getting paid in
cash that smelled like perfume
tonight's yes
he helped introduce bin laden to 72
virgins former navy seal and co-author
of the new book the way forward rob
o'neal
[Applause]
tour calendar has less dates than a high
school chess club
actor writer and comedian jamie lisao
she tells her parole officer these shows
are community service fox news
contributor cat tim
finally reading his palms takes longer
than reading war and peace my massive
sidekick in the nwa world television
champion
tyra
jamie welcome back from alaska it's
still there good to be back yeah yeah
yeah yeah i have a theory maybe you can
oh not a theory but i have a i have a
query
not a theory okay
shouldn't trump i know they are totally
different
shouldn't trump forgive the debt
wouldn't that be a gentlemanly thing to
do and he would get so much press it
would be a gen i think that's a good
idea and i do love though when someone
has the resources to fight someone
that's making an allegation like this
because they don't always have it that's
true but i think that'd be a cool thing
to do i love this story i love
everything about it by the way i just i
checked dude stormy daniels not her real
name really yeah
because you need to have like a funny
poor name for her real name sarah stroke
a lot
which is so weird it is weird that's
very weird it's all it's funny too they
call her in all the articles they call
her a porn star right isn't it funny
that they're all porn stars like you
never run into someone and they go what
are you doing oh i'm a porn extra yes
never and you go oh what did you do in
the last movie you go oh i was the
husband i just left for work before the
pool guy came
never hear that yeah yeah there's no
porn character actors yeah right you
know what i mean but what vindication
right i'm glad when something turns out
the way it was supposed to and someone
doesn't just have to settle and pay out
for something they didn't do so i was
happy to see this that's good that's
good rob congrats on the book thank you
may it go to number one i just started
reading it there's a lot of advice not
just on killing terrorists
but other advice too like like torturing
them
in front of their families
waterboarding is not torture we've
talked about this we were talking about
in the green room
that's funny you were saying the pool
thing too that's funny when they say
like oh the plot is preposterous you can
imagine where it goes from here he
cleans the pool
no but like you mentioned the uh being
in the military and uh i've been to sea
on ships i've been um afghanistan iraq a
lot of places and on behalf of a
military want to thank stormy daniels
for her service yes yeah it's like it's
like when i found my brother's laptop
and all this porn found out he was in
all of them
i i actually feel sorry for her okay i
feel sorry for her because she got
played
by that bastard right there avenatti and
uh he
he ran her i'm well nope not gonna do it
he
he took nope
these are tough jobs he did he did some
very bad things yes he did some bad
things he manipulated a lot of people he
used her as a tool
[Laughter]
cat
yeah yeah i don't know like cat it's sad
because on the one hand she's just
trying to make a living and she got you
know men have not been kind to her no i
mean again this whole thing do you
remember how huge this story was it
i'm not talking about a penis or
whatever okay
language
don't work blue so
she went from being like a porn star to
like a regular star like she was on snl
and she probably really liked the
attention and that she wanted to keep it
going that was probably what this was
really about and i get it i've done dumb
things for attention too but thankfully
all those cost me only my self-respect
right not
no money she's what's weird is avanade
when she when this happened she figured
that with avenatti she would never have
to work again right and that's what he
was probably telling her like oh we'll
make sure we're you know you're going to
be a star you're going to be here but
now she's gonna have to work for the
rest of her life to make that 300 grand
because the the the the uh the shine has
gone off her star nobody wants to go
around what that's how can you find
anything sexual in him he can though
anything you could shine
you know what i'm i know exactly where
yeah i'm right here yeah oh my god i
never thought this was going to go into
this one you 100
is going to go this way she's going to
be a dirty little man look around
you ever bleeped a whole segment
i had such a good point but you know
what we're going to move on
segments in this segment yes too many
segments hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else